so now you've played with the limits for
a little while now son of your house
really daddy you want to how to
differentiate a hold on your functions
right we've been looking at
we start with polynomials didn't we and
powers and all that kind of thing they
were moved onto logs and Exponential's
and now we're showing these guys in the
mix okay so let's rehearse what are some
of the results that we've been showing
over the last few days so I probably
should have written these bigger that's
just a bit so the view side it is
because the derivative course is by the
way yes but just because it's been in
Georgia my attention recently cuz I've
been teaching you seven introduced
that's not - that's a difference look at
that it's negative so okay derivative of
tan is sinh squared okay now before we
move on to these guys okay from all of
these you can read off the same results
if you introduce a new function inside
here so for instance if I was
differentiating not just sine X but sine
of some function what does this tell you
well we know how it works you
differentiate the insides then you
differentiate the outside we've been
doing this for a while now just not with
trig functions okay so I don't know what
F is but I know it's derivative would be
it would just be a dash so I
differentiate the inside and then I
differentiate the outside which is sine
which turns into cos so do because we
didn't carry that down if I
differentiate laws on some function okay
then that's going to be f dash and then
it'll be negative sine so I suppose I
should put that and then if you
differentiate tan of some function then
invariably you get F dash you're always
gonna appreciate the inside and then
SEC squared of whatever functions okay
no then we have these guys to play with
okay so these are our reciprocal
identities now you probably like me
can't just think oh yes that's what it
is off the top my head so let's give
them a go we have a couple of options
don't we Cossack is the reciprocal of
it's it's science it's one other side
right so I could consider this as this a
new question or I could consider it as
this and you chain right which would you
prefer
let's keep training go shall we so how
do I do that what I do differentiate the
inside which becomes cos now what did
the outside so that negative comes out
the front and the power reduces by one
okay looks like Missy doesn't it can we
use you need this up at all this is
minus cos over sine squared sorry
negative cos so what can I break that up
into I don't lie don't like fractions
well I haven't at least I have one cot
in there there's a closet aside so I can
say it negative
sorry negative quite but that leaves a
sign on the denominator so that should
become procession then negative person
there's how result isn't it true but I
suppose we should expect that when you
are dealing with fractions right okay
what would you expect from sick
should we do it the same way what should
we do why do they do the question rule
let's just see how it turns out let's
see if it turns out the bathroom anytime
soon SEC is the reciprocal of cos okay
so you've got your you and your V okay
I'm gonna go - all over V squared that's
zero negatives cancel I get sine squared
that turned out so bad after all
kind of cuz of this one right means that
you - will always be equal zero sex
now this looks very similar what we had
here but it's not quite is it the
difference
the sign in the cards you become a tan
and that leftover Cod on the bottom will
become up and we tend to write back we
almost never write up my father we tend
to write in the other direction now you
can see some symmetry here can't you
which I suppose we ought to expect
because of the symmetry that came up
okay
differentiating caught that before we do
it just think if you could guess would
you get what do you expect to get here
we got sex squared
mmm let's try it out now here you're
kind of pinned down you do have to
consider it as a question okay so I'm
going to go V you - - you yep all over V
squared now what's that up on the top
side squared plus squared they're both
negative yes so I actually just get
minus one on the top right you see that
sine squared cosine squared plus cos
squared with a minus sign on science
pizza what's that
that's negative curse okay I think some
of you did predict that actually because
you can see SEC squared here okay you
can fill out the rest of this table it's
not that hard
now now that we have all these different
kind of variations right I can combine
these in all sorts of different ways I'm
not going to turn this into a pose and
comments question now that you have
treat for instance you can handle a
question like this you know Ted on the
square root of x minus 1 or the
derivative of e to the power sine X or
the derivative of all log X you can do
all of these right and now that we have
all of these extra pieces there's so
many more ways to combine them now
here's what you could do you could think
serious maybe news coming up and enjoyed
this ugly table and if we completed like
the rest of it right yeah no
Exponential's and lots of polynomials
you know it looks a bit like you know
you've got this kind of angry table that
says you just got all these things to
memorize and they all look like each
other and they're very hard to
distinguish from each other
it could think about it like that
I remember thinking about it like that
in some ways that's my teacher and I've
spent a lot of time thinking about a lot
more time of you guys have I've sort of
come to a different way to look at these
and I hope it'll help you a little bit
which is kind of like you these guys
right then as a set of rules you must
memorize even though you must memorize
but I try to think of them kinda like a
bunch of excited little kids and they're
kind of like you know cool you know look
at me cause they all in their own way
give you an insight right there are all
shortcuts towards something significant
about each of these graphs that's what
you leave news on and let me give you an
example let's go after this guy okay 10x
right now I think
where's I think he is like a little kid
mercy I just came to show you something
cool okay the question is what what a
derivative is meant to tell you about a
functions what what geometric properties
do you that it's like a gradient right
so let's just think about this how many
of you know what SEC squared looks like
probably not many of you off the top of
your head so let's just quickly work it
out it's not that hard okay SEC square
is 1 over cos squared so we better know
what whatever cause it looks like which
means we've been know what cause looks
like so here we go
so if I take the reciprocal of that
what's gonna happen to it the first
thing you notice is their asymptotes
because this thing passes through 0 a
whole bunch of times so every time
passes through 0 sorry bad scale every
time pluses to your you're getting a
nice return okay
you're getting as injured by the way at
PI or 2 3 PI on to for that pilot suit
that seems like an important coincidence
doesn't it there are the asymptotes what
is the rest of this thing look like okay
well you know that Fritz is at a point
like that causes equal to 1 so it's the
reciprocal one this just what are you
lamenting that part right and point like
this you're going through negative 1 so
what's the reciprocal of negative 1 also
negative 1 you can play this game so
you're going to go through all of those
crosses that are just true now what's
happening here you start one but then
what happens to projects what happens to
you to nominator it drops like a rock
the denominator gets really small if the
Danada gets really small what does that
mean about your whole number the whole
buffer gets bigger so it's skyrocketing
off like that down here you're getting
the same effect but everything's
negatives so you're getting continue
okay so all of these upside down
disconnected bits that's sick that's
just regular so what happens
let's play the same game I've got your
one key what's the square of one still
one okay
what's the square of negative one it
comes up here
that's one again this comes up okay so
now I'm not gonna be down here well that
we should expected that because squares
are always positive or zero right now
what's happening to this [ __ ] well it's
increasing and decreasing [ __ ] what
happens when something that's increasing
increasing fast gets squared it goes
faster all right so he's dying he
thought he was increasing before now
he's going like crazy right now what
happens here well this guy is just the
same as this but negative so when you
square it he forgets these negatives
because so it's okay so these four
shapes up here that's six square okay so
this guy's telling us he cool look at me
I'm the derivative of tan X I'm the
grading of tan X everywhere now have a
look think about what Ted X looks like I
wish I'd brought another color whenever
you notice it's like it has its
asymptotes at pi/2 3.25 line - that's
not a coincidence
why is it a coincidence what's what's
tan tan is sine over cause it has
asymptotes when causes zero just like
sex squared is 1 over custom tote when
close X is equal to zero you ought to
expect that they would have the same
asymptotes it's not a coincidence that
is x squared and it's not a coincidence
that cos x squared see what's going on
cuz that's over sine okay what's going
on can I draw it here it's approaching
that asymptote like that this is the
shape you're familiar with there we go
so what does this tell you what does sex
we're doing what is it jumping out of
its skin to show you well the derivative
of tan is firstly it's always positive
of course it is because it's always
increasing everywhere it's always
increasing at least when it exists it's
increasing okay
when is it increasing must and it's all
close to the asymptotes close to any
asymptotes I decide you've got these
skyrocketing values which is why 10x
goes what are these things when the
gradient has a stationary point that
tells you that the second derivative the
concavity right should be zero right
which is exactly what you find you get
these points inflection all the way
along so I mean do you think do you need
to know that probably not okay but it
shows you what is he's trying to tell
you it's not just a rule to memorize is
tell you something important about 10
and all the rest of them are doing the
same